there's something there's our one thing
out there that Betty White still wants
to do just last month Kevin finally
found something that Betty hasn't done
we have to set up YouTube meeting right
oh very much fitting her sense of humor
is as sharp as ever and over the years
we have tried to get the secret to her
fountain of youth you never seem to age
ever oh yes say that to be nice I'm
saying that to be serious well I
appreciate it with all my heart I don't
have to believe it but it's great to
hear her passion for animals has helped
keep her young for her very first et
interview but then sixty-year-old didn't
mind being upstaged he's not too
thrilled with his kids Morris I know
you're a star but you're forgetting your
roots and at age 66 she was raring to
ride an elephant okay
she's outlived all of her Golden Girls
co-stars Betty was actually the oldest
of the ladies no it isn't well this
season we're writing the other girls out
and Rose is doing it in one it's just
gonna be you know the Betty White Show
and sorry about that when the cast of
The Mary Tyler Moore Show reunited in
1991 she admitted she was just as big a
fan as the rest of us it is heaven I
tell you we all walked into the makeup
trailer together
and the the sides bulged and we haven't
stopped talking since it's just I cannot
tell you the thrill it is to be back to
get it
Betty lost her husband game show host
Alan Ludden to cancer almost 36 years
ago and although she has no children of
her own animals are her babies I love
children and the only problem children
they grow up to be people and I just
like animals better than people
she's been awarded seven Emmys and truly
deserves the title of legend I never
thought I would still be blessed with
working you just don't expect
but think you fade off into the sunset
well the song sets every night but I
just won't go away
[Music]